why isn't it that staff at the New York
Times and virtually any of the major
media institutes why aren't they
thinking about this topic more
frequently
you'd have to ask them Kurt you know I
I don't know I mean except that you know
there's still a stigma and that stigma
is definitely still at play uh and the
New York Times covers so many topics
they would consider to be way more
important than this such as the war in
Ukraine you know all kinds of things
um they certainly have gone with the
Chinese balloon story but that's not
really the kind of story we're talking
about so
I I really can't answer that and it's
especially mystifying to me because the
stories that we've done so far have
gotten huge attention for the New York
Times
uh you know a huge number of people
viewing them the readers obviously loved
the stories and want more
but I can't speak for them I just know
that it they don't cover it on a regular
basis they will cover things like a
hearing that takes place in Washington
or when the report comes out you know
the odni report they have one of their
people cover that
um
so
yeah you I don't know uh people would
have to ask them people will have to
write to the editorial Department write
to them and say we want to see more
coverage of this
but I can't I can't speak for them but I
do know that that stigma is pretty
powerful at the New York Times maybe
more so there than a lot of other media
because they are considered the paper of
record and they're very cautious and the
Chinese balloon story you're referring
to what happened in Yukon yeah I'm
referring to everything starting with
the shooting down of the Chinese balloon
going forward from that I mean that's
been such a huge thing in the media and
the times has been doing a lot of
coverage on that and Elaine Cooper's
been part of that can you walk us
through that storyline and the North
American issues that have popped up as
of a couple weeks ago I wish I you know
I've been so busy in the last few days
with other stuff I wish I I don't feel
like I'm as informed about this as I
would like to be but you know as we all
know there were there was first the
Chinese balloon that was shot down
which was clearly a spy Bloom and that
was made very clear shot down over the
Atlantic Ocean and then over this past
weekend we had three more objects shot
down right we had one in Alaska on
February 2nd which they said it was
about the size of a small car
another one in Yukon in Canada and
February 3rd and then another one over
Lake Huron on I believe February 4th I
think those were the dates and
you know they're they're just these
small objects and uh we don't there has
been no definitive I mean not enough of
a definitive statement let's put it that
way about what they actually were or are
and they're having trouble collecting
the debris but um so there's a there's a
kind of chaos around all of this and and
it's become this sort of
you know it's been kind of
heightened and there's this escalation
that's been going on every day around
this topic and
I just think I mean it's clear to me
that these are not alien objects and
that's been stated
um even though that some people say the
door is still open but clearly they're
not they're most likely Chinese
uh and
you know it's it's a little confusing as
to why that has not been stated more
clearly I don't know if people if
there's just um people aren't talking to
each other there's not an organized
messaging that's going on around it they
haven't found the debris from the
objects so they don't maybe don't feel
comfortable saying definitively what
they are although I suspect they do know
what they are so I don't know it's um
you know the objects are clearly not
E.T though why do you say they're
clearly not the statement has been made
by the press secretary for Biden who
said that they have no indication that
their extraterrestrial their Air Force
officials that have said the same thing
and they don't behave in any
that they don't demonstrate the kind of
behaviors that we're used to when
something is extraterrestrial uh I don't
so I just and I have sources that have
told me uh also from the intelligence
community that they're not that they're
Chinese basically
um and I think the the bigger issue here
has to do with the geopolitical Dynamics
uh between China and the United States
and there's there's a lot going on
I think behind the scenes around all of
this that
we're not privy to and hopefully over
time more will come out they don't want
to State publicly this is Chinese
because it would cause more of a
conflict than they would like I I you
know I don't know if they're just not
100 certain or if they're yeah there may
be reasons why they don't want to say it
or they want to use this these UFOs as
kind of a cover so they're sort of
hedging it
or they're just not clear and maybe some
of the Congress people feel they've been
left out they want to know more and then
one person says this and somebody else
says that and it's just messy uh but I
think there's you know there's more that
we I'm sure will come out over time but
I just um I feel clear that these are
not we don't have to speculate that
these are some kind of non-human
technology or something I don't I really
don't think that's the case
I'm going to read a comment from Ross
coltheart and I'll put on the screen
because it's fairly wordy I asked them
for a question and he gave me a comment
that's okay cool you can just comment on
his comments just so people know he has
been really focused on this and he's
brilliant and he's he you know he's
really really uh been monitoring
everything and thinking a lot about it
more than I have so let his comment
carry the day sure there is clearly
dissent between sections of the Pentagon
notably the U.S Air Force and the White
House when National Security adviser
Jake Kirby saw that the dod had publicly
briefed journalists these objects were
likely balloons he clearly knew enough
to directly overrule that assumption
they are not balloons you do not fire
Sidewinder missiles at balloons and
balloons not have the structure clearly
described by the pilots someone tried to
lie to the public and for the first time
in decades the White House has overruled
that lie fascinating right and the and
and all I I mean I agree with Ross and
also the White House has said that they
want to set up their own h agency to
look into this which was kind of a shock
too because we have the the arrow the
Department of Defense entity doing its
job and now suddenly the exact you know
that the president announces that he
wants to set up another task force
so
um yeah it's all these contradictory
issues that are going on at once as Ross
points out and hopefully it's gonna
it'll smooth itself out over time did
you receive a considerable amount of
pushback or reproach from your article
from the 2017-2019 one you mean by like
Skeptics or from the editorial teams at
the New York Times or from your
colleagues or from the broader Community
I'm curious to know where does the
pushback come from and where does the
adulation come from where does the
praise come from
changed everything you know so I don't
know I'm sure there are people that have
criticisms of it
um and I know that you know
um
we didn't reference the OSAP program
which has upset some people
um
but I don't know it's hard hard for me
to answer like where does criticism come
from where does price come from I mean
it was just like this was sent off like
a cannonball you know reverberated
around the world and I think the focus
was just oh my god look these are real
in the Pentagon studying them
uh and what's gonna happen now I mean
we didn't we were not focused I mean I
did not I don't remember getting people
critical at the time the time this thing
came out and yeah I mean Harry Reid was
on the record and he didn't object to
anything in the story I mean it was all
you know
that was really the point of it
and the fact that this was explosive to
me indicates that the public is so
desperate to hear about this topic I was
speaking to Ryan Graves recently
actually Ryan Graves has a podcast for
people who don't know what's called
merged and he interviewed me on the
podcast which should come out in a few
weeks and I say that I don't think
there's a stigma I think we have a
collective illusion of stigma and I go
into this topic called Collective
Illusions which means we behave one way
in public because we believe other
people behave that same way in the 1960s
most Southerners were against
segregation but they thought that their
neighbor was for it so they would say no
I'm for it and I believe that stigma is
similar where we feel like other people
stigmatize it so we don't talk about it
much and that's why what you did is
extremely important what Ryan Graves is
extremely important legitimizing the
issue by getting people to talk about it
so I don't think we have a stigma
problem I think we have a cowardice
problem and the fact that your article
was explosive indicates that people want
this topic there are people that I
interview math professors physics
professors that you would think they're
the skeptical type they come to me
afterward and say Kurt why aren't more
people talking about this top subject
I'm like why don't you bring that up on
the podcast like show that you're
interested in it yeah I mean that's
basically what I mean by a stigma I mean
I think your points valid yeah people
are afraid to say what they really feel
because they think other people won't
accept it
but that's really because of us that's
that's the that's really how a stigma
operates
I mean why are they afraid to say it
because there's this taboo because they
are afraid they'll be ridiculed or not
respected and so it's all I mean I think
it's just you're basically saying you
know we're basically saying the same
thing it just depends on how people
operate in the face of that stigma but
I I mean I just you know there is still
this hesitation however you want to
describe it to be public about it and
but it's changing rapidly
it's changing rapidly I think
um more and more people are are not
afraid of it now
yeah great great so what's some of the
most compelling evidence that you've
seen on this which we referred to
earlier which is a synonym for the
phenomenon that it's not something
terrestrial it's something that's
extraordinary in a sense or if it is
terrestrial it could be a breakaway
civilization but I mean it's not
something ordinary
yeah well I mean
the huge question I mean the best I mean
I think what what's really compelling to
me is to look back into the 50s and 60s
back in the time when we you know it's
really hard to imagine that the
technology that we're observing could
have existed then I mean now many cases
could be
American Technology or maybe even
Russian or Chinese right but in those
early days it's it's just inconceivable
that any country had the technology that
was observed and the objects being
observed then were this demonstrated the
same behaviors that we see now
uh and our government was very very
concerned about it and it was the Cold
War so they made sure to try to make it
go away and not let the public come
involved and you know that's when all
the programs for ridicule and everything
else became operative but
how could that have been Russian Chinese
or American Technology back in those
early days I mean that is a very basic
question and then you can look back at
the government documents from the time
and see what kinds of observations were
made
and um you know it has to do too with
the credibility of the people observing
these things as you know as general
Samford said in that famous speech in
1952 after those
flyovers in Washington DC you know
credible
what did he say credible observers of
you know these people credible observers
of relatively incredible things I mean
and this has been going on for decades
there are hundreds and hundreds of
reports
that are very hard to explain away
um and so you know you put it all
together and you have this picture and I
think for me personally it's also about
people that I have talked to with
clearances many of them off the Record
for years who from whom I have learned a
lot
um and of who have helped you know
validate for me a lot of things that you
know are off the Record so I can't talk
about them but
uh
you know when you put it all together
it's like if you just spend years
digging
a nation you know you'll start to get to
the truth which would be well this could
be explained this way or that way but
it's the opposite it's like the more you
study it
the more it becomes unexplainable and
I'm talking about the only the very best
information you know military documents
military observers cases involving
multiple levels of evidence such as you
know radar and photographs and multiple
witnesses that are military or Pilots or
police officers
um just a wealth of data and you see the
behavior of these objects and I'm sure
I mean you know of course most sightings
that people have can be explained
so we're you know once you narrow it
down to the to the ones that are really
spectacular for which there's enough
evidence that you can eliminate
at least any known explanation according
to being man-made right or at least as
far as anybody would know at that time
if it's not super super secret
um you just you just see over and over
and over again these things happening
and eventually
you know there's plenty of evidence as
as is well documented and now you that
you know we have our our government
acknowledging that now we have
uh US Government involved in you know in
investigating something here so they're
not wasting their time investigating
something that doesn't exist or
something that they feel they can easily
explain
so I mean we don't have the answers yet
but
there are so many interesting cases and
so much history to this
um and it takes a long time to wrap wrap
your mind around all of that but um
it's it's hard to imagine that all these
cases that we know about that are on the
record could all be explained through
some conventional explanation when
they've been studied as thoroughly as
they have been by the best people with
the ability to do that and then the
whole realm of classical oh sorry the
whole realm of classified information we
have to constantly remind ourselves
that I mean I think Lou Elizondo said I
forget the percentage he said maybe 10
of what the public knows is out you know
we only may we might know maybe 10
percent of what is known on the
classified level about this phenomenon
so you we have to constantly remind
ourselves of that that there's so much
more and if it was something easily
explainable
I think we'd know by now I I think the
Navy would have been happy to tell us
the gimbal video was an airplane if if
that's what they had figured out it was
and you know
they have enough expertise and enough
experts to go to within their realm of
within you know all the agencies that
they have access to
to get that video analyzed properly and
make a decision based on not only a
video itself but the the classified
information they have that goes along
with it that we don't even have
you know so if if that video is
explainable they'd be happy to tell us
that you mentioned that the way that it
ordinarily works when you investigate a
topic so let's say physics or particle
physics there's a pruning of the
possibility tree down and down and down
to a singular solution generally but in
this one it seems like more and more
questions open up can you walk us
through your mental models what did you
think what did you learn and why did
that change and what did it change too
I'll try it's a big question I mean I'll
try
um I mean when I first started you know
I received this report from the some
French officials I don't know I don't
know how if people have probably heard
me talk about this before this French
report called the cametta report and
basically these high-level French
officials that study this thing for a
number of years and they were Admirals
and Generals and police officers and
engineers and people like that and they
had that they had written in this report
what they call the Extraterrestrial
hypothesis right
they said they thought these cases could
best be explained through that
hypothesis and it was only an hypothesis
it couldn't be proven
but it was a sort of notion that we're
being visited as I said earlier being
visited from somewhere else and so I
think for the whole first 10 years of my
or maybe more of my work on this I kind
of held in my mind that the ones that
aren't explainable I agree with those
those generals and Admirals they're most
likely explainable through the
Extraterrestrial hypothesis and that was
sort of
the way I viewed it you know it was um
and my next story was about Aviation
safety issues and about these objects
flying around and impacting aircraft but
it was always about their physical
objects that have come from somewhere
else it's fairly simple
um and then you know over time
um I just learned more about the the
more the more what they call High
strangeness aspects of this uh related
phenomenon or you know things that
affect people's minds it's all kind of
what I said before Kurt
um you know and Jacques valet is has
been writing about this for decades I
mean Jacques valet the famous UFO writer
and researcher and investigator and
scientist
has always had a theory about UFOs that
was much broader and all-encompassing
than the Extraterrestrial hypothesis and
a lot of people didn't like him for that
and now I think it's you know we we can
see that he was really ahead of his time
because now we we just more aware of the
multi-dimensional complicated aspects of
the the way the phenomenon manifests
itself
um and I mean books like skinwalkers at
the Pentagon for instance
uh which document some of the things
that happened related to the Skinwalker
Ranch in which you know one of the
things that's always stuck with me was
the description of this blue orb
that went into the body of a man who was
driving a car and his daughter was with
him and it actually penetrated his body
and then he became severely ill after
that
now something like that that's not a
physical craft that's come from another
planet right it's something else and
these these orbs are described by a lot
of people uh
and so the phenomenon just takes on this
broader umbrella
uh over time and I did I wasn't so aware
of that in earlier in my career
um and it's harder to write about
because
when I'm ready for the New York Times
I'm not going to go into that kind of
stuff because it all has to happen in
steps you know they're the members of
Congress are not really interested in
that they just want
to deal with the National Security
implications of these physical objects
flying around our Navy ships you know
but they did include in legislation
which was passed you know they had the
legislation this year and some
legislation last year
uh that they wanted psychological and
medical effects on people to be studied
and reported to Congress
so there is an acknowledgment on their
part that they're aware of the broader
some of the broader implications of this
um and then how it how it can affect
people and if it was just
yeah so I mean
it's hard for me to describe it but I
just I have much more of a sense that
it's really is difficult to explain what
this thing is and then it has so many
more components to it
than I ever realized before and it's
connected to Consciousness and it's
connected to inter other dimensions and
it's uh manifests in all kinds of
strange ways and
some of the phenomena at Skinwalker
Ranch you have to ask are those really
UAP or are they something else where's
the what is the borderline where where
it's not UAP anymore that's something I
was thinking right when we say that
there's this phenomenon and then we keep
talking about how it's so varied what is
the relationship between them all aside
from it being anomalous which by the way
someone knocks on my door and I open and
no one's there that's anomalous we
wouldn't call that part of the
phenomenon unless there was also a blue
light associated with it or some orbit
and stuff right so what is it that
strings these together such that we can
even put the label to categorize them as
the phenomenon
that's such a good question it really is
I mean I I think sometimes maybe it's
not clear
but I mean it's I think as far as the
Pentagon is concerned I mean they have
their their characteristics that relate
to the way they behave they have their
physical their data showing that the
presence of some object they're more
focused on the physicality of it and the
National Security implications so
there's a whole universe that they can
sort of wrap around that you know and
not the rest of it doesn't really come
into play but for for other people who
are more interested in this in a bigger
way
um that's where those questions come
into play What where do you draw that
long line I don't know you know when is
it a UAP and when is it something else
uh and I think probably people have
their own ways of seeing that uh in
terms of how they personally
interpret what that term actually means
uh uh I think it's yeah I don't think we
have any set agreed upon
you know definition of what
characterizes
an unidentified area anomalous
phenomenon and what doesn't
I mean just that term unidentified
anomalous phenomenon yeah that's you
know it's so broad we don't even have
Ariel in there anymore you know yeah so
that it's partly because they wanted to
be able to include the ones that go in
the water but it broadens it up to mean
who knows what right yeah
um so yeah it's just a fascinating
fascinating question to ponder and
there's so many such a variety of
experiences that people have had
engaging with these things that you
don't know
even almost how to define it anymore
it's not like we're saying with physics
with you can just get down to one
equation right
it's like yeah
opposite is happening with this it's
like it just gets less that way over
time although there's more data being
collected at the same time you know but
there's another dimension I think of the
phenomenon that's not you can't pin it
down it's just not something that it's
almost like science isn't the right tool
sometimes to even try and and capture
this it's beyond our capability at some
level what is the connection between
uaps and Consciousness you mentioned
this
yeah I wish I and you know again what's
meant by that then
I mean I yeah that's maybe a better
question it's but you know
does human consciousness in some way
determine
not just the presence of the UFO but
does it play a role in what how a person
perceives it or how a person what kind
of experience a person might have in
connection to that phenomenon I mean for
instance there will be witnesses to the
same phenomenon but their experience of
it is each person perceives it in a
different way they'll describe it
differently they'll have a different
kind of experience
what is that about is that because of
the consciousness of the of the human
being that's in the presence of this
thing even though the thing itself was
just something out there
you know it's it's like um
and also sometimes people have an
encounter and then they develop these uh
abilities you know not just Clairvoyance
or telepathy they develop kind of more
psychic powers or however you want to
describe it after that as if they have
their Consciousness has been impacted in
some level we don't understand you know
they're able to perceive more uh on the
on the on the realm of the Paranormal
than they were before
uh so
and then there's questions about whether
it's connected to
the Outlook what people consider to be
uh the afterlife where we go when we die
um people are studying that question a
lot it's it's
um it's mysterious and it has and then
the whole question of Time how we Define
time
comes into play I mean um there's a show
uh there's a series on Netflix called
Dark
I don't know if you ever see if you've
ever seen it it's a German series but
it's it's really profoundly deals with
the question of time travel and it has a
lot of messaging in that show that I
think relates to
how we perceive this phenomenon and What
the deeper level of it is
and so you know you can just keep going
peeling back the layers and peeling back
the layers and um you go to places with
this that
just expand your mind and you can't
contain them in a certain way you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy